I grew up very aware that their infinite
number of degrees and ways of being
Jewish it has occurred to me that just
about every Jewish person thinks that
they're Jews who are too Jewish and
others who are not Jewish enough and it
goes right from the people who have for
refrigerators who think the people with
a preferred res or excessive down to the
people who never go in the Holy holidays
but they'd like telling Jewish jokes and
I had quite a lot of the range in my
family my dad's father Dave Pinsky when
I was a kid he had a bar called the
Broadway tavern and he had been a
bootlegger in the well when liquor was
illegal he was in the liquor business
and when I knew him he was married to a
Methodist woman and had wife three and
he had a Christmas tree without
exaggerating was probably seven or eight
hundred feet tall and uh my other
grandfather the house was kosher though
my parents were kind of secular people
in a nominal way we were affiliated with
the Orthodox synagogue and we did have
two sets of dishes and we didn't have
bacon in the house if my dad and I want
to order a pizza with pepperoni on it we
had to eat it off the piano bench you
couldn't put it on the table that degree
of being Jewish I think people often
make the mistake of inventing and kind
of a nice ethnic mom and dad for
everybody if you're Italian or Jewish or
your wasp or your Irish until you
actually know a person I think we make
the mistake of filling in kind of
cliches from some sitcom or movie and I
didn't have a nice old Jewish mom and
dad like most people they were weird
I have a poem which I observe that for
reasons they're kind of hard to explain
my mom missed my bar mitzvah and ten
years later she missed my brother's just
didn't take in the ceremony and that
sounds as if the family was divorced or
they lived all over the place no just at
the crucial moment you realize you don't
have the right hats you stay home or
something or other and you don't just
explain things like that you have to
write for Russian novels to explain
you